SONYA HAYDEN: I love songwriting, and
particularly songwriting
for musical theater because
it's all about telling a story.
So the music is helping
to tell the story,
the lyrics are helping
the libretto is helping
to tell the story.
So it's all organically
combining to --
for the purpose of
telling a story.
And so I really
love that process
of thinking about how is each
note and each song really going
to help forward the story?
Why am I making these choices?
What music would
work best with this?
What am I saying lyrically?
Last semester I took a course
with Stacy Wolf and a couple
of guest lecturers from the
New York University Musical
Theatre Writing
program, one of whom
is a Princeton alum, Robert Lee.
And we talked all about
how to write musicals.
So all of this has been
really helpful in writing
my thesis, which is a musical,
an original musical.
The title of the show
is "The Luckiest Girl".
And there's a song
called "Lucky Girl"
in which the
protagonist is thinking
all about how lucky she is to
be getting ready for her wedding
and she, of course, is
feeling unsure about
whether this is the right
decision to be making.
And in order to find
my way into that song
I was thinking about how
incredibly lucky, on one hand,
I am to be here at Princeton.
But I think that
sometimes, here, there
are so many demands, and
so much is expected of you,
and sometimes it can feel hard
to meet all those expectations.
So that was sort of might
way into writing that song,
was from these
personal experiences
of being at Princeton and
thinking about how lucky I
am to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]